hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and with the
confirmation that we are entering the
final saga in the one piece story and
with oda personally confirming that he
is about to draw all the mysteries that
we have been wondering about for 25
years it is the perfect time to talk
about luffy's ultimate power is this
final saga which will feature massive
showdowns with blackbeard the world
government and more going to unlock new
powers within luffy powers that take him
even beyond gear 5. gear 5 is still
fairly new to us but will this be his
final form for the rest of the series or
can we expect one more ultimate power up
as the story reaches its long-awaited
climax in this video we will talk about
what luffy's ultimate power up and final
form might look like and where his
powers could possibly go beyond gear 5
so let's get into it you guys know the
drill if you enjoy our one piece content
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps us
out with that youtube algorithm and of
course if you're new to the channel or
you've been watching us but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
remember that subscribing right now and
hitting that notification bell is a
completely free but very real way of
directly supporting the channel finally
this video will contain one piece manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned okay so when we
think of gears we often think about cars
and many people have compared luffy's
gear-based power system to the gears of
a car many cars have five forward gears
and the reverse gear although other cars
do have six forward gears plus reverse
but is it possible that after gear 5
luffy may not be going into a gear 6 but
instead in reverse and if so
what would that even mean
well in order for a reverse gear to
actually be a cool power up it would
have to involve more than just luffy
moving backwards or something i mean
sure luffy trying to attack opponents
with his back and buttocks would be
pretty confusing at first and it might
catch some opponents off guard but
that's hardly something that deserves
being referred to as a new gear however
if that reversing part was referring to
something like reversing time then we
might be on to something picture this
during the final epic clash between the
straw hats and the blackbeard pirates or
between the straw hats and the world
government one of the people closest to
luffy is killed imagine zorro or sanji
or any of the straw hats dying right in
front of luffy and he is completely
powerless to protect them because maybe
he's already injured or his hands are
full with another opponent this would be
absolutely devastating for luffy and it
could trigger a fundamental break within
him a break that could have a radical
effect on his awakened devil fruit we
know that the nika fruit symbolizes
freedom itself and that once it awakens
it frees its user to do practically
anything that is within the grasp of his
imagination in the moment when one of
his closest friends dies right in front
of him the one thing that luffy would
want to do more than anything else in
this world and with the force of his
entire being is to turn back time so
that he could prevent his friend's death
from happening so what if in that very
moment gear reverse is unlocked the
power of luffy's will and imagination
allows him to rewind time if only for a
second or two allowing him to save his
friend's life before they are killed
from that point onward luffy can turn
back time by a second or two whenever he
is in a difficult position which allows
him to gain the upper hand in battle
against even the strongest opponent now
yes this would be cool to see and it
could function similarly to bismarck
waldstein's geass in code geass bismarck
can see a few seconds into the future
and this allows him to anticipate his
opponent's next move if luffy could
rewind time by a few seconds it would
have a similar effect he would be able
to anticipate his opponent's attacks and
counter them by reversing time to before
the attack was even launched but
although this could be interesting to
see it would also be really overpowered
and pretty freaking broken unless there
were some serious limitations to using
this ability all of luffy's future
fights would lose their tension since we
know that luffy will be able to
outmaneuver his opponent every time this
problem could be alleviated if luffy can
only use gear reverse on rare occasions
or when the situation is particularly
dire but not all the time another way to
potentially alleviate the brokenness of
such a power would be to make it very
difficult to control which means that
luffy could actually lose control of
gear reverse and cause massive problems
for himself and his friends by messing
with time itself there is a decently
popular theory out there that states
that luffy could actually be the
original joy boy who ended up getting
stuck in a time loop for example he may
have unlocked gear reverse but he lost
control of the power and it eventually
sent him too far back in time all the
way back to the void century since luffy
doesn't have the ability to jump forward
in time he became the original
historical joy boy the man who fought
alongside the ancient kingdom the man
who left a treasure on laugh tale and
the man who left that apology on fishman
island the reason why roger laughed when
he got to laughtale was because he
realized that the man he had been
looking for hasn't even been born yet
and that is why roger says that he
wishes that he could have lived in
joyboy's time after all if toki's devil
fruit could bring her from the void
century all the way up to the present
time then who's to say that a godly
devil fruit like nika can't bring its
user back to the void century now of
course a lot of us one piece youtubers
like to go crazy with these time
traveling theories because it's fun to
think about such hypotheticals but
realistically any storyline that
features luffy traveling back in time
would be incredibly difficult to pull
off and any time loop is a potential
disaster when it comes to plot cohesion
so while i could potentially see luffy
unlocking gear reverse and gaining the
power to go back in time by like a
second or two i don't see him going all
the way back to the void century or
getting stuck in a time loop i could be
wrong here but time loops are a
narrative minefield full of potential
plot holes so i just don't think that
oda is going to go in that direction let
me know what you guys think about luffy
potentially traveling back in time down
in the comments oh and while you're at
it don't forget to feed that ruthless
youtube algorithm by hitting that like
button alright now let's bring in axel
to talk about another possible theory
for what gear 6 might look like as
animak just mentioned as youtubers we
are legally required to give some of the
more crazy and outlandish theories that
we have first after all this is the
world of anime and manga and if you're
not gonna go crazy with your imagination
then you're just missing out on a lot of
really fun opportunities and speaking of
imagination as the gorosei explained the
true power of the nika fruit is within
the imagination of its user as we've
seen with luffy becoming more and more
confident and experienced with his devil
fruit his abilities have all become
increasingly complicated and creative he
isn't just throwing long punches he is
boosting his blood flow he is inflating
his arms he is taking on entirely new
forms and essentially becoming a full-on
rubber hose cartoon when his fruit
awakens and he enters gear 5. and at the
point where imagination being made real
is on the table it's kind of hard to
think of a next step i mean
what's more powerful than your
imagination being reality well this idea
isn't exactly a gear six per se but i
think of it more as a final point for
gear 5 not a new form in itself but the
full actualization of the current form
and most importantly this brings themes
of imagination full circle into the core
theme of the entire show that of course
being dreams the idea at the basis of
one piece is to follow your dreams no
matter how crazy or ridiculous they are
and a seeming requirement for being a
straw hat has always been that you need
to have one of those crazy dreams not
just the straw hats though these slaves
of the world nobles wish that they could
be free just as nika had freed them in
the past the people of fishman island
wish to be able to live as equals under
the sun and so on and so on and i think
that this will be the ultimate
quote-unquote power of gear 5. it won't
be that luffy is limited only by his
imagination it will be that luffy will
allow the dreams of those around him to
be unlimited by reality in essence luffy
will become a man who can make the
dreams of those around him come true and
again this is more of a symbolic
actualization than a true new form but i
do think that it's something cool that
fits into the themes of the story yet
another possible direction that gear 6
could take us in is leaning into the sun
god aspect of sun god nika there has
been a lot of debate about how much the
original joy boy who was almost
certainly the previous owner of the nika
devil fruit is influencing the actions
and decisions of luffy after his devil
fruit awakening all the laughing and joy
that gear 5 luffy exhibits during fights
suggests that joyboy's will may be
having an effect on him but i think that
we'd all agree that overall luffy is
still luffy his personality his goals
and his dreams have not changed because
of his devil fruit awakening but what if
gear 6 takes luffy's transformation to a
whole other level and instead of just
being a man called monkey d luffy our
protagonist turns into an actual godly
being at least temporarily what if he
somehow becomes one with joy boy and son
god nika to the point that he becomes
almost unrecognizable to us for the
duration of that transformation think of
this as luffy entering some sort of
avatar state and becoming a god-like
being with the ability to unlock powers
that he himself never even dreamed of we
can assume that at least initially luffy
may not be able to control himself in
this state so his personality could
change he may behave more like a stoic
godlike being and less like the goofy
and energetic person he normally is
this might also be where the power of
the voice of all things finally comes
into play this strange telepathic
ability is probably the least developed
aspect of the one piece power system and
with the story in its final stage and
with oda directly confirming that he is
now going to draw all the mysteries of
this world we can be sure that the voice
of all things will finally be explained
perhaps luffy in his sun god gear 6 form
will be able to tap into this power more
than anyone before him which would allow
him to gain access to new knowledge and
new abilities that he never had before
he may even gain the ability to control
other creatures such as zunesha and
command them to do what he wants he
could also gain access to the hidden
knowledge and powers possessed by every
previous holder of the nika devil fruit
including of course the original joy boy
from the void century i find this
concept to be pretty interesting because
the possibility that luffy might lose
control of himself in this form at least
temporarily could create an interesting
conflict as the straw hats try their
best to bring sangha luffy back to his
senses i know that a lot of people hate
the idea of the original joy boy or sun
god nika somehow possessing luffy and
taking away his individuality and i
agree that this would be a terrible idea
if it were permanent but having luffy
temporarily lose his senses as he
evolves into a godly being and then
fighting to regain his individuality
while still being able to use the new
power up could be a really interesting
plot point if it is handled well granted
that is a pretty big if finally you know
if animak is bringing me on for a video
he probably wants me to talk about
history or mythology so let's talk about
some sun gods specifically in norse
mythology we have the god soul in greek
mythology there's helios the egyptian
god ra not that one the real one and the
hindu god sudia these all share the fact
that they are gods of the sun but more
importantly they guide the sun across
the sky in norse mythology after the sun
was created by the molten sparks of
muspelheim seoul was charged with
leading its path using a chariot and two
horses called arvak and ausvin all the
while seoul himself was being chased by
the great wolf skull helios in greek
myth who is often conflated with apollo
has the same responsibility minus the
wolf he still uses his chariot and he
actually has four flaming horses which
is just objectively cooler raw the
embodiment of the sun for ancient
egyptians would ride his barge across
the heavens during the day and then
descend into the underworld at night and
soodia much like helios also guided the
sun with the chariot and seven horses
and this is far from a comprehensive
list as there are tons of other deities
who do the same kind of thing but the
important thing here is that we have a
sun god riding something and pulling the
sun behind them now let's revisit an
older theory that we shared on the
channel a while ago in which animak
talked about the possibility of the nika
fruit being uranos in some way or
another he continued that vivi would
hold the key to finding pluton as she's
a nefertari and shirahoshi obviously is
poseidon essentially linking the three
ancient weapons to people with specific
abilities rather than tangible things
and here's the last jump that we need to
make by combining those ancient weapons
with these sun deities from around our
world although admittedly we do need to
make a few changes in our world nations
are connected by roads so we often saw
things like chariots being used in
mythology but in a world like one piece
where everything is mostly ocean it
would make sense to use a ship instead
and similarly horses would have to be
dropped and we could replace them with
something like sea kings so altogether
we have our sun god luffy riding atop
his chariot a ship like pluton and being
pulled by his steeds the sea kings in
this theory we're saying that luffy's
final form is unlocked by awakening his
fruit embodying nika and coming in
contact with both poseidon and pluton
it's this union of the three ancient
weapons all coming together in one piece
and just as our own son deitz had done
following this union as it set sail
would bring about a new dawn personally
i like these more symbolic evolutions of
gear fifth a lot more than the idea of a
possible gear 6 or gear reversal but
definitely let us know in the comments
which you like best for the future of
luffy's abilities thanks a lot axel i
really really liked that last theory and
it would make for such a great climax to
the story as it brings all these
different components together into one
piece
guys show axel some love by checking out
his own youtube channel link in the
description and of course if you enjoyed
this video and you want us to keep it
going with the one piece content don't
forget to like and leave a comment do
you believe that luffy will receive
another major power-up after gear 5 and
if so what do you think that power is
going to look like what new abilities is
this final form going to grant luffy let
me know down below do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and hit that
notification bell if you haven't already
it is a completely free and quick way to
directly support the channel it helps me
out a lot as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys